These days, you’d be a fool to leave a movie
theatre as soon as the credits started to
roll, because you’re more than likely to
end up missing out on something important
or fun if you do.
The days when credits were nothing more than
a list of the names of the people involved
in the making a movie are long gone.
Now, audiences are treated to mid-credits
scenes and post-credits scenes, as well as
interesting messages and funny jokes that
are hidden within the credits themselves.
Of course, the key word there is “hidden”.
Often, it’s hard to spot these fun inclusions
with the naked eye – the mass of text included
in any given movie’s credits can make it
almost impossible to see them – but they’re
definitely there and we’re going to show
you a selection of the funniest.
Here are 10 hilarious jokes hidden in the
credits of popular movies (in chronological
order).
Frozen
In Disney’s insanely popular 2013 animated
movie Frozen, Kristoff – an iceman and one
of the movie’s main characters – unashamedly
claims that all men pick their nose and eat
the contents, grossing Anna out in the process.
Rather hilariously, Disney opted to avoid
any booger-related lawsuits by placing the
following message in the movie’s credits:
"The views and opinions expressed by Kristoff
in the film that all men eat their own boogers
are solely his own and do not necessarily
reflect the views and opinions of The Walt
Disney Company or the filmmakers."
Carry On Abroad
The Carry On movies are some of the most iconic
in British comedy history.
Focusing on the very British comic tradition
of the music hall and indecent seaside postcards,
they tickled audiences over the course of
no less than five decades.
1972’s Carry On Abroad – a movie about
vacationing in the sunny Mediterranean - is
proof that jokes have actually been appearing
in movie credits for a very long time, as
the movie’s “Technical Director” is
listed as being “Sun Tan Lo Tion”.
Airplane II: The Sequel
The Airplane movies are some of the funniest
spoof movies ever produced and the people
behind them ensured that the laughs continued
after the credits started to roll.
1982’s Airplane II: The Sequel poked fun
at the job titles of some of the people who
worked on the movie in a very humorous way.
Every movie has a “Best Boy”, but Airplane
II listed the movie’s “Worst Boy” as
being “Adolf Hitler”.
And the job title of “Gaffer” was followed
by the question “What’s a Gaffer??”
which, come to think of it, is actually a
genuinely intriguing question!
RoboCop
Although it did include a lot of satirical
material, 1987’s RoboCop could hardly be
described as a comedy.
However, there was certainly a funny little
inclusion within the movie’s credits.
In place of the usual piracy warning, there
was a terrifying but undoubtedly very humorous
threat to any people who might be considering
unlawfully copying, selling or showing the
movie.
The warning made reference to the robotic
creations in the movie itself and read “This
motion picture is protected under the laws
of the United States and other countries and
its unauthorized duplication, distribution
or exhibition may result in civil liability
and criminal prosecution by enforcement droids.”
Naked Gun 33 1/3: The Final Insult
Like the aforementioned Airplane movies before
them, the Naked Gun series of movies are some
of the greatest spoof comedies ever produced.
All of the Naked Gun offerings provided laughs
in the credits, but none more so than 1994’s
Naked Gun 33 1/3: The Final Insult.
There’s no way we could cover them all,
but some examples included a message telling
the owner of a Honda Accord to report to the
parking lot because they’d left their lights
on, a list of people who were cut from the
movie in spite of the fact that it wasn’t
their fault, and a very demanding message
telling the audience “DON’T LEAVE YET!”
Pulp Fiction
Quentin Tarantino’s 1994 cult classic Pulp
Fiction follows the exploits of a plethora
of Los Angeles mobsters and criminals, and
includes a memorable scene in which Tim Roth’s
Ringo holds up a restaurant with a gun.
In the scene, Ringo asks the restaurant’s
coffee shop manager – played by Robert Ruth
– if he’s going to be a hero.
Ruth’s character tries to respond by saying
“I am not a hero.
I’m just a coffee shop manager”, but is
cut off before he gets the word “manager”
out and ends up saying “I am not a hero.
I’m just a coffee shop”.
As a result, he is hilariously listed in the
credits with the character name “Coffee
Shop”.
Mallrats
Mallrats is another cult movie, from 1995
and directed by Kevin Smith, which follows
two best friends as they seek refuge in a
local mall after their girlfriends dump them.
Smith likes to mention his parents in the
credits of the movies he directs and Mallrats
provides the best and funniest example of
him doing that.
In the credits, he simply thanks his Mom and
Dad “for having sex all those years ago.”
It’s simple, straight to the point and pretty
damn funny.
Mr. Popper’s Penguins
2011’s Mr. Poppper’s Penguins sees Thomas
Popper – played by Jim Carrey – inheriting
a group of penguins from his father.
Although some of the penguin scenes used seamless
CGI, there were also some real trained penguins
used in the movie.
As a result, a message was included in the
credits to clarify that none of them came
to any harm in the movie – but it also included
a humorous add-on about Carrey.
Specifically, the message said that “No
penguins were harmed in the making of this
film.
Jim Carrey, on the other hand, was bitten
mercilessly.
But he had it coming.”
Guardians of the Galaxy
2104’s Guardians of the Galaxy is a superhero
movie that brings together a group of space
misfits in the Marvel Cinematic Universe;
The outlaw Star-Lord, the assassin Gamora,
the vengeful Drax, and the endearing and unlikely
pairing of the talking raccoon known as Rocket
and the tree-like humanoid Groot.
Rocket and Groot were, of course, created
using CGI, but Marvel Studios still opted
to include a humorous message in the credits
that stated "No raccoons or tree creatures
were harmed during the making of this film."
Deadpool
Although these particular jokes in 2016’s
Deadpool movie credits can hardly be described
as “hidden”, audience members still had
to be paying attention in order to see them.
Occurring at the start of the movie, rather
than at the end like the other entries in
this list, Deadpool’s opening credits didn’t
list any of the names of the people who worked
on the movie, but simply listed a load of
stereotypes instead – these credits are
basically a roasting of every Hollywood film
studio in existence.
For example, the producers are listed as “asshats”,
the director is named as “an overpaid tool”
and the writers are labelled “the real heroes
here”.
Brilliant.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 hilarious
jokes hidden in the credits of popular movies.
Which of these jokes made you laugh?
Did we leave any out?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one!